[Music]
[Music]
by the rules and there will be cost with
examples will be made
a former JTF unit turned paramilitary
warlords the true sons are trained
disciplined and hell-bent on using the
combat expertise and overwhelming
firepower to eliminate all enemies and
rivals in the pursuit of domination over
Washington DC in their view America was
founded through bloodshed and through
bloodshed a new society will rise
[Music]
[Music]
after the events of Black Friday the
dollar flew quickly found its way into
Washington DC amongst the chaos and
panic the JT have attempted to control
the spread of the virus by setting up a
quarantine on Roosevelt Island
Colonel Antoine Ridgeway was given the
responsibility to administer the
quarantine and ensure that everything
ran smoothly he was there to make sure
that people were getting food and water
and the medical help they needed however
over time Ridgeway grew tired of
witnessing the growing levels the
tragedy and despair from the front lines
he started losing faith in the
government in the JTF stability to save
Washington DC after coming to the
conclusion that there was no way that
anyone would survive if they were to
continue with their current way of doing
things
Ridgeway decided that was up to him to
make the hard calls and ensure the
well-being of his men Antoine Ridgeway
studied the reserve officers Training
Corps a tertiary education based program
for training officers of the United
States Armed Forces
following on from this he joined the
Maryland National Guard eventually
achieving the rank of colonel
Rajoy also had a lucrative career as a
salesperson and often uses the skills he
gained through this time to enhance his
leadership style Ridgeway is ambitious
and has a strong desire to lead he will
always dominate the conversation and
expresses his concerns if he disagrees
with people when placed under intense
pressure he is in his element he has no
problems dealing with the stress and can
easily make quick decisions during his
time with the JTF Ridgeway was dutiful
and possessed a confident leadership and
planning skills as he achieved the rank
of colonel and was tasked with
administrating the quarantine on
Roosevelt Island he can tolerate those
who questioned his priorities as he can
easily persuade them into agreeing with
him
however Ridgeway will not tolerate
insubordination and worse desertion
he will personally execute those who try
and loyalty not just empty words but the
virtues I expect you to live by every
day the foundation upon which the true
Sun stands we are at war our enemies are
the hordes of degenerates who will see
this city burn and the failed remnants
of a corrupt government the same
impotent government was lost our fine
country - sicknesses rule we will
destroy them all but we can only win
this war if we stay true to the cause as
each other
loyalty is the glue that holds us
together without it our foundation will
rock crumble and fall so when I
encountered disloyalty where I have eyes
such rocks I must cut it out before it
spread please now these soldiers wore
the same note as you did they swore to
be loyal to the cause to me they proved
to be neither
instead they demanded their post and
tried to sneak away in the night they
are off previous days on this service we
are at war and in war the punishment for
desertion is death no please we were
going to come back
as a strong believer in the need for
authority and discipline Ridgeway
decided to take matters into his own
hands on Roosevelt Island and
frustration and fear for the city's
future
he deployed guards around the quarantine
with the order to not let anyone out he
started to redirect resources coming
into the quarantine bleeding people
starve to death
and withholding medicine not good sir he
took a bullet
we tried penicillin but his wound has
festered I thought morphine might ease
his pain how's that supply cash
truthfully sir we're running low
anarchists and supplies of manpower -
we've got civilians piling up outside
the doors under these conditions it's
difficult to separate the infected from
the healthy the doctor is expecting a
new shipment this afternoon but it
almost certainly won't be enough for
everybody
pack all this up and move it out to the
barracks but Sir we can't just are you
questioning my orders trooper well no
sir right away sir what about the
patient in his eyes the second week were
over he did so his number-one priority
came to secure the future of his own
mean
ridgeway's actions were tainted by his
willingness to do whatever it took for
the well-being of the soldiers and his
repulsion of the sick due to the chaotic
state of the city he was able to abuse
his authority for a long time before the
commander of the JTA found out and he
was imprisoned violating the Uniform
Code of Military Justice for the crimes
of unlawful detention failure to obey an
order or regulation and murder you will
therefore be stripped of all ranks and
titles pertaining to your service in the
Armed Forces and detained until further
notice mr. Ridgeway would you like to
make a final statement very well however
it did not take longer to loyal members
of his unit freedom in ridgway's eyes
he'd done nothing wrong
according to him he was the only one
with a realistic and viable solution to
the situation therefore the betrayal
from his fellow officers filled him with
rage and hate towards the JTF in the
federal government as soon as he got out
together does mean from his former unit
and a stockade where he was held
prisoner together they captured the JTF
officers that had him imprisoned and had
them executed according to the true
Sam's survival of the fittest is the
only way to survive Washington DC due to
their access to weapons equipment and
expertise the true sons are now the top
dogs in Washington DC this newfound
power has made winter vicious and
arrogant police intimidation cruelty and
violence have become the key factors in
the true sons paramilitary dictatorship
the true sons do not think twice about
making examples out of people to ensure
obedience either you join them or die
whoever and whatever stands between the
true sons and general ridgway's position
as absolute rulers of Washington DC will
be eliminated Ridgeway seems to have
established a cult personality with an
affection as his self promoted himself
to general and is the fierce loyalty of
those under his command he also views
himself in the true sons as the only
hope of restoring order in DC
quaint I like that thank you sir
you know home says a lot about a
person's character you know what your
home tells me about you no sir it says
you're a Sidious and orderly perhaps a
little too much but you're certainly
responsible must be nice to live in
peace and quiet but fortunately for us
there's a price for defending
communities such as this but at least
you keep it out of harm's way general I
before we came here we ran into a
neighbor of yours he didn't seem to
appreciate the good work we do around
here and I couldn't accept that not
after all my men have been through but I
don't think we're gonna have the same
problem like I said the house tells you
a lot about a person I've seen it's your
compassionate generous please just take
what you want
that really is mighty kind mr. Williams
people like you I'll make it a real
difference is inspiring I'll be back in
a week
I trust you have more forests man the
true sons demand tribute from other
settlements ridge Wayne has men believe
it's mutually beneficial as the
settlements get protection in exchange
the true sons get supplies despite some
of the settlements wanting nothing to do
with the faction or believing the
demands are too harsh consequently
Ridgeway considers those who offer
tribute willing or by force to be
considered by default part of the true
sons and thus as a citizen he expects
them to obey
general there's a woman here says she's
a representative of the theater
settlement wants to speak with you
what about she wants to negotiate
negotiate why would we want to negotiate
with those people
stand by sir I'll ask her
sir she thinks the truth could be
mutually beneficial
shooter lieutenant sir shooter and dump
her body with those cowards we'll find
it and if anybody else comes to
negotiate she with them too
understood uh yes sir
being comprised of former JT of members
and possessing military-grade technology
training in discipline the true sons are
seen by the other factions as being the
most dominant faction within DC and thus
the biggest threat the outcasts despise
them for the quarantine and treatment of
people on the island the hyenas have
joined up with the outcasts because
their war against the true sons anikó
shows that the hyenas and outcasts are
willing to cooperate with each other to
take out a skort of true sons guarding a
building the true sons are actively at
war with the hyenas and appear to be on
the offensive against them the true sons
are hostile they're not actively at war
with the outcasts an audio recording
revealed that when the outcasts
overthrew and took over the Roosevelt
Island quarantine center the JTF before
they became the true sons decided to
Manas them rather than send in War men
in neutralizing early on simple true
sons left the group feeling that
ridgeway's intentions were far too
brutal they went on to set up their own
community where they could assist
refugees providing food and shelter what
they believed they should have been
doing all along the settlement the
castle was one of the most active in the
city but due to failure to meet true
sons demands Ridgway eventually ordered
the bombing of the community its general
Ridgway now look you guys can go to your
thing and we may lift a finger to stop
you but we're done being part of it
we're gonna stay right here in this
castle and make our own way and you'd
best be okay with that
I'm not sure that general will be well
he knows where to find us
the castles largest nose territory
general Ridgway mike snow captain Wilson
he's a deserter
we don't interest traders but rank sorry
sir
word has it he's operating an open-door
policy he was always weak
they've got refugees crowding in by the
hour the worst this city has to offer
nothing but degenerates and backstabbers
and what good are they that place will
become a breeding ground for the virus
we must tackle the problem at the source
it's time to start cleaning up this city
let's see how this DC 62 yours holes up
in gained a first introduction to the
true sons is where they had dug and
secured a strategic hold on the vupoint
Museum but once the division
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
following this after suffering a number
of defeats at the American History
Museum Air and Space Museum Space
Administration HQ Jefferson Plaza and
the Lincoln Memorial they retreated back
to the final stronghold in the Capitol
building division agents with the help
of the JTF and civilian militia
assaulted this facility after sweeping
through the complex the true sons
general and leader Antoine reach way
made his final appearance to try and
stop the division once and for all with
the death of Ridgeway and the remaining
true sons garrison at the Capitol
building the true sons have since been
scattered across DC attempting to finish
the job against the division and now the
new invading enemy the black tusk the
true sons are now at war with every
faction and a vying for control of
positions within DC although now
leaderless I don't think we've heard the
last of the true sons Ridgeway had a
number of loyal officers under his
command and it's only a matter of time
before we see one of them take the reins
the introduction of the technologically
advanced black tusk has likely had them
set back a bit and reassess the
situation but when the time is right
we'll be seeing them make another strike
back of the city soon the true sons had
come about through desperation in a time
we society it all but completely fallen
apart however it was from the actions
alone early on in the conflict that
other hostile factions came to be like
the fanatical cult-like group known as
the outcasts who see the true sons is
the ones primarily responsible for the
quarantine on Rosa Island and the
barbaric treatment of the people who
were imprisoned there
this is as far as I've managed to get
with my research on the true sense as I
said I don't think this is last we'll
hear of them with coming updates and
extensions of the storyline I can almost
guarantee that we'll be talking about
this group further in a future video
anyway I'll leave this one here thank
you very much for watching this video
I'll catch you in the next one Cheers
save do you're into the clinic and the
food goes to the storage by the mess
halls but those crates back on the truck
wait what we're not wasting any more
supplies on these people put them back
private sir what the hell are you doing
colonel they are already dead doctor are
you insane they need care what about the
staff collateral damage no take your
hand off my soldier if you go ahead with
this I will report your car what's up
bother gate sergeant looks like you got
a riot brewing Lock and Load put it down
[Music]